merci pour ce clin d'oeil
cinématographique bienvenue à cette
table ronde sur intelligence
artificielle et démocratie alors
l'intelligence artificielle est devenue
en quelques décennies seulement un outil
très puissant facilitateur de nombreux
usages et services et qui reposent sur
des progrès fulgurants de la technologie
l'accès à des volumes importants donnés
la capacité d'entraînement des machines
la puissance exponentielle des
ordinateurs qui peuvent traiter
justement ces quantités de données mais
il y a quelques mois il y a une rupture
qui est arrivée dans l'IA qui s'appelle
Tchad gipiti et qui nous a tous percutés
parce que elle nous a percuté nous grand
public en nous faisant percevoir une
autre dimension de l'intelligence
artificielle que nous n'avions pas
peut-être perçu il y a c'était plus
qu'un super assistant pour médecin
transporteur ingénieur concepteur
c'était une
potentiellement une véritable
intelligence capable de générer des
contenus pourquoi pas des émotions et
donc de nous remplacer en quelques mois
Tchad jipiti a réuni 100 millions de
visiteurs uniques donc cette révolution
que nous connaissons mal et on va faire
en sorte de l'éclairer aujourd'hui nous
fascine nous ébranle nous inquiète
parfois parce qu'on pressant qu'elle va
changer beaucoup notre façon de vivre
d'apprendre de travailler de créer on
peut s'interroger c'est ce que nous
faisons aujourd'hui sur l'impact qu'elle
aura sur notre société et
potentiellement sur notre modèle
démocratique alors faut-il en attendre
le meilleur un contact plus direct entre
citoyens entre citoyens élus plus de
participation civiques une réaction
politique plus rapide au changement de
société à l'opinion ou au contraire
faut-il en attendre le pire la
manipulation de l'opinion par des
fausses informations
habilement diffusée et très bien ciblé
une société de surveillance généralisée
une prise de pouvoir par les puissances
mondiales les plus avancées en la
matière
face à tout ça tout le monde se pose des
questions la preuve en vidéo
je suis allée poser quelques questions à
des inconnus dans la rue à propos de
l'intelligence artificielle je vous
propose de les écouter qu'est-ce qui
vous vient à l'esprit lorsque l'on
mentionne l'intelligence artificielle
aux dernières innovations qui ont été
montré ces derniers mois
pensez-vous que nous les IA serions
capables à l'avenir de vous remplacer je
pense pas je suis plutôt quelqu'un qui
ait confiance en l'homme on va dire que
je pense que les diables nous aider au
quotidien
ce qui nous rend humain je pense pas
qu'ils peuvent la voir
influencer des choix politiques
de créer de nouveaux concepts on
pourrait être utile à la politique donc
servir de cabinet de compter je suis pas
sûr que toi une très bonne idée devrait
pouvoir
non je pense que il y a certaines choses
qu'on peut juste je sais pas j'ai
l'impression qu'il faut avoir une
conscience puis comme des pensées
humaines pour pouvoir vraiment bien
conserver comprendre tout ce que nous
décisions peuvent avoir comme
répercussions fait que je pense pas
qu'on puisse qu'on devrait autoriser
à apprendre à influencer les décisions
politiques
isolant computer
alors face à toutes ces questions
faut-il accélérer la course à
l'innovation ou au contraire faut-il
conforter
renfermir notre régulation pour nous
protéger des dérives et est-ce que les
deux démarches sont compatibles l'Union
européenne après avoir régulé récemment
les gafas s'attaquent à l'intelligence
artificielle avec un acte sur
l'intelligence artificielle qui est en
phase finale de négociation
est satisfaisant est suffisant pour en
parler c'est un sujet très vague en une
heure seulement j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir Jean-Noël Barrault ministre
délégué en charge de la transition
numérique et des télécommunications ça
fait presque un peu désuet ce terme mais
c'est ainsi sandrogozzi mon collègue
député européen et puis deux éminents
spécialistes référents du comité
interministériel sur l'IA je finirai par
Alexandra donc Luc Giulia qui est
informaticien franco-améric Julia et
co-concepteur de l'assistant vocal Siri
il est aujourd'hui directeur
scientifique chez Renault après une
longue carrière dans de multiples
entreprises en 2018 challenge titré sur
vous en disant le gourou de l'IA auquel
on ne dit pas non et donc vous êtes
aujourd'hui membre du comité
interministériel pour l'IA et puis
Alexandra bensamun qui est professeur de
droit à l'Université de Paris Saclay et
une grande spécialiste du droit d'auteur
avec qui j'ai le plaisir de travailler
maintenant régulièrement au Parlement
européen elle est également membre de ce
comité interministériel et personnalité
qualifiées du Conseil supérieur de la
propriété littéraire et artistique merci
d'être parmi vous je vais d'abord me
tourner vers notre ministre
pour lui poser une question il y a six
mois environ des milliers de chercheurs
appelés à une pause sur les recherches
sur lia
dans le même temps Elon Musk a fait
également demander cette pause peut-être
pour des raisons moins nobles plus
commerciales parce que il n'était pas
tout à fait prêt et encore la semaine
dernière
ça matman donc il dirige qui dirige open
II et qui exploitent lui demander une
régulation peut-être aussi pour des
raisons qui sont pas tout à fait avables
alors est-ce que la créature échappe à
son maître est-ce que notre monde nos
valeurs sont en danger faut-il arrêter
la course à l'innovation ou au contraire
accéléré est-ce qu'on peut perdre nos
fondements démocratiques à quoi
pouvons-nous nous attendre sur l'IA
merci Laurence bonjour à toutes et tous
je voudrais d'abord dire à quel point je
suis honoré heureux d'être entouré de
deux de nos députés européens secrétaire
général du PDE qui sont très investis
sur les sujets numériques et en
interagit très régulièrement parce que
ce que nous faisons en France sur les
questions numériques et intimement liées
à ce que nos parlementaires portent au
niveau européen et puis Luc et Alexandra
ont accepté de venir débattre avec nous
aujourd'hui de ces questions
et je suis très heureux qu'il l'ait fait
Guidel c'est beau mais c'est loin on n'a
pas toujours la chance de pouvoir les
avoir et comme Laurence l'a dit le
président de la République a décidé de
leur confier ou de les associer à cette
à cette à ce comité qui va éclairer les
choix que nous aurons à faire dans les
mois à venir chacun des deux est connu
et reconnu internationalement
Laurence a rappelé leur mérite Luc Julia
il a créé cyril a aussi ses chemises à
fleurs que que tout le monde connaît
désormais et Alexandra sur les questions
de droit elle aussi est extrêmement
respectée pour répondre à la question je
pourrais d'abord dire que non il n'y
aura pas de grand remplacement de
l'humain par l'intelligence artificielle
pour deux raisons simples la première
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de volonté
artificielle et cette affirmation Blaise
Pascal dont on fête cette année le 400e
anniversaire de la naissance la faisait
déjà quand il regardait sa calculatrice
en réalité l'ancêtre très lointain de
chat GPT qu'il constatait que la
calculatrice faisait des opérations qui
semblaient plus complexes que celles
qu'un animal pouvait faire mais que
contrairement à l'animal et à l'homme la
calculatrice n'avait pas de volonté il
n'y a pas d'intentionnalité l'intention
la volontaire reste humaine c'est la
première raison pour laquelle il n'y
aura pas de grand remplacement et la
deuxième c'est qu'il n'y a pas
d'expérience artificielle et que notre
intelligence elle résulte des
interactions constantes de nos 100
milliards de neurones avec notre
environnement avec nos cinq sens et donc
par exemple on écoutait à l'instant
Jean-Paul Mattei parlait de fiscalité la
manière dont on va percevoir ses propos
dépend du temps qu'il fait à Guidel
dépend des émotions qu'on a ressenties
pendant la journée dépend de plein de
choses auxquelles évidemment la machine
elle-même est tout à fait insensible et
pour ces deux raisons le fait qu'il n'y
a pas de volontaire artificielle le fait
qu'il n'y a pas d'expérience
artificielle il n'y aura pas de grand
remplacement en revanche ces
intelligences artificielles vont nous
être extrêmement utiles pour relever un
grand nombre de défis et je voudrais
citer deux exemples de grands défis le
premier c'est celui de la transition
climatique du de la lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique et grâce à ses
outils qui peuvent analyser des
quantités astronomiques d'information
qui peuvent analyser des images d'une
manière beaucoup plus pointue que ce qui
est accessible à l’œil humain nous
allons pouvoir mieux préserver nos
ressources naturelles nous allons
pouvoir réduire l'empreinte carbone de
notre habitat de nos mobilités de notre
industrie nous allons pouvoir mieux nous
adapter aux conséquences du dérèglement
climatique et puis sur une autre
transition qui est la transition
démographique et puis le grand défi de
la santé là aussi c'est outils là vont
nous nous changer la vie ils vont nous
permettre d'éradiquer tout un tas de
cancers qu'aujourd'hui on ne sait pas
soigner parce qu'on les détecte beaucoup
trop tard l'intelligence artificielle
parviendra en regardant l'imagerie à les
détecter bien plutôt on va pouvoir avec
la prévention personnalisée réduire
considérablement le risque
cardiovasculaire on va pouvoir trouver
des remèdes pour des maladies orphelines
contre lesquelles on avait jusqu'à on
avait fini par renoncer à lutter et on
va réussir à trouver des remèdes et des
vaccins dans les cas comme ceux qu'on a
connu pendant la période de la covid
donc beaucoup de choses
extraordinairement positives pour le
bien commun mais évidemment c'est un
outil qui peut être dévoyé comme tout
outil pour faire du mal et évidemment
que l'intelligence artificielle
générative peut ne peut conduire à ce
que notre débat public soit inondé sous
les fausses nouvelles que nos réseaux
sociaux soient inondés ça a déjà
commencé par des contenus
pédopornographiques que les acteurs
malveillants s'en saisissent pour
déployer des cyber-attaques et même pour
en faire des instruments de guerre alors
oui se posera la question de
l'encadrement et de la régulation mais
avant ça et pour répondre à la question
de Laurence il nous faut accélérer parce
que la priorité absolue bien avant de
réguler c'est de maîtriser cette
technologie pourquoi parce que la
domination technologique entraîne la
domination économique et la domination
politique nous ne parviendrons à réguler
correctement l'intelligence artificielle
que si nous maîtrisons en France et en
Europe cette technologie sinon nous
serons comme nous l'avons été depuis 20
ans à la remorque et en défensive comme
nous l'avons été face au Gafa pendant 20
ans impuissant à leur imposer des règles
l'année dernière l'Europe a grâce à
l'action de nos députés grâce à l'action
du Président de la République a adopter
deux règlements majeurs qui enfin vont
imposer des règles au garfamil a fallu
20 ans et pourquoi avons-nous dû
attendre 20 ans parce que nous ne
maîtrisions pas la technologie donc nous
devons accélérer pour maîtriser la
technologie parce que c'est une
nécessité vitale et parce que nous en
avons les moyens parce que il se trouve
que pour une fois une révolution
technologique nous la situation d'être
leader parce que depuis Blaise Pascal il
y a 400 ans la France n'a jamais cessé
d'être une grande nation de sciences et
de mathématiques et que partout dans le
monde à l'image de Luc Julia ce sont des
Français qui dirigent les grands
laboratoires d'intelligence artificielle
qu'il soit public ou privé et que depuis
quelques mois depuis en réalité les
premiers frémissements de cette nouvelle
révolution des figures de l'intelligence
artificielle comme Luc Julia ont décidé
de revenir en France pour y développer
pour participer à cette révolution donc
c'est une nécessité vitale nous en avons
les moyens accélérons maîtrisons cette
technologie dans les mois qui viennent
et nous pourrons ensuite réfléchir
sereinement à la manière dont nous
voulons la réguler
alors justement Luc Julia je vais me
tourner vers vous puisque vous incarnez
le monde des ingénieurs et je voulais
savoir qui dirigera le monde demain
est-ce que ce seront toujours des
politiques élus sur notre continent
moins démocratiquement où est-ce que ce
sera une élite d'ingénieur adossée à des
grandes multinationales qui finalement
auront la même mise sur ce que nous
pensons ce que nous consommons comme
information quel est votre vision sur
sur ce futur
donc je vois pas le futur
mais d'abord Jean-Noël merci beaucoup
parce que cette démystification on en a
besoin et c'est très très clair et bien
exprimé donc merci beaucoup de Luc
Julien mais il faut le dire il faut le
répéter ces intelligences ne sont que
des outils et on en a la maîtrise et
donc du coup parce qu'on en a la
maîtrise c'est notre décision cette
société de demain c'est notre décision
c'est décider collectivement ce qu'on
veut faire et ce qu'on veut faire de ces
outils parce que nous les maîtrisons
mais il y a un mot clé si on veut si on
veut vraiment maîtriser tout ça c'est
l'éducation c'est à dire qu'il faut
s'éduquer sur ces je parle pas
d'éducation au niveau des écoles ça mais
j'en parle aussi en fait mais à tous
niveaux à tout moment il faut s'éduquer
pour comprendre ces outils parce que
effectivement comme tout outil on peut
l'utiliser à bon ou un mauvais escient
et donc comprendre quand on utilise
comment l'utiliser correctement donc ça
c'est super important mais si vous
voulez pour répondre exactement à la
question est-ce que c'est des robots qui
vont nous
rediriger ou diriger les pays plus tard
vous savez il y a un film qui date de
2003 qui s'appelle Idiocracy alors c'est
un film complètement idiot comme son nom
l'indique mais la bonne nouvelle c'est
qu'il dure qu'une heure 5 ou 1h10 donc
il est pas trop trop long mais je vous
conseille vivement de regarder ce
film-là parce que c'est un film qui a
été fait donc en 2003 pour critiquer la
politique d'éducation de bouche 1 aux
États-Unis et donc pour montrer que une
société non éduquée peut être contrôlée
par des robots alors il faut dire que
les robots ici c'est entre guillemets
parce que évidemment vous voyez que dans
le film alors je vous dévoile pas la fin
parce que de toute façon c'est stupide
donc il y a pas de problème bon bref
mais ça montre qu'il y a une société
complètement inéduquée stupide c'est
celle qui est élu Trump et puis après il
y a au-dessus donc des fameux robots
mais qui sont en fait contrôlés
évidemment ces robots par une autre
couche de la société qui sont ceux qui
connaissent cette technologie et qui
vont aller diriger les
non pas forcément parce que les éduquer
c'est pas forcément les ingénieurs c'est
ceux qui ont envie de s'éduquer et donc
il faut que nous collectivement on ait
envie on a envie de comprendre la bonne
nouvelle avec chat gipiti si vous voulez
le fait que ça soit arrivé comme vous
l'avez dit 100 millions d'utilisateurs
entre janvier et février 2023 la bonne
nouvelle de chat gipiti c'est que ça a
été accessible ça coûte tout le monde
100 millions de personnes a pu
l'utiliser très très rapidement et donc
on a pu tous jouer avec et s'apercevoir
de la puissance mais aussi des limites
et donc on s'est posé des questions on
s'est on s'est interrogé entre nous ou
tous et donc on a compris que
l'utilisation il fallait faire un peu
attention parce que ça racontait des
bêtises et donc on a compris aussi que
potentiellement ça pouvait faire c'est
fake news ça pouvait créer des des deep
fake comme on dit aussi donc c'est juste
la fois qu'on a accès à l'outil en fait
on a une opportunité de le comprendre
mieux et donc de le maîtriser mieux
merci beaucoup
alors sur l'autre jambe l'innovation la
maîtrise l'éducation il y a aussi la
régulation je me tourne vers Sandro
puisque en ce moment au Parlement
européen nous sommes en train de
finaliser l'acte sur l'intelligence
artificielle donc tu pourras parler un
peu sur des grandes lignes mais dans le
même temps on septembre donc il y a même
pas un mois dans son discours sur l'état
de l'Union la présidente de la
Commission européenne
Ursula fenderlayenne a fait de la
question de l'intelligence artificielle
un point tout à fait crucial de son
discours en appelant à un GIEC de l'IA
donc une organisation de gouvernance
internationale donc est-ce que on peut
déjà dire qu'il y a un constat d'échec
sur la régulation européenne
et laissez-moi aussi dire en tant que
Jean-Noël voulait rappeler en tant que
secrétaire général du parti démocrates
européen combien je suis heureux de voir
que Guidel est toujours en France ou
c'est d'idées de participation de
mobilisation donc bravo à vous tout et
tout si vous êtes là et ça ça vraiment
ça nous encourage encourage énormément
dans notre travail non ce n'est pas un
échec les seuls niveaux possibles les
niveaux minimal possible pour reprendre
les contrôles sur une question sur
laquelle nous devons avoir les contrôles
c'est celui européen moi je crois que
l'intelligence artificielle est dans
cette phase historique la plus grande
opportunité dans l'humanité dispose
mais comme toutes les opportunités quand
elle a un impact sur la société elle a
besoin
d'une approche d'une régulation on a
besoin de s'assurer que cette
opportunité soit véritablement exploitée
dans le respect de nos valeurs
fondamentales dans les respects des
endroits fondamentaux de nos libertés
fondamentales et en cohérence avec nos
objectifs stratégiques industrielles et
je dirais même géopolitique c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons indiqué
et c'était
Jean-Noël est rappelé grâce avant tout à
la volonté et l'audace du président de
la République qui est en 2019 avant et
la elle avait fixé la question du
numérique de la transformation du
numérique comme un des enjeux de la
souveraineté européenne parce que c'est
un enjeu de souveraineté et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons commencé
à introduire des nouvelles règles nous
avons adopté Laurence il faisait
référence pour la première fois au monde
il doit sur le service numérique
complète qui traite tous les aspects la
protection des consommateurs la lutte
contre des informations les obligations
des modération contre les risques à la
sécurité collective des plateformes on a
adopté première fois au monde il y a sur
la sur les marchés numériques qui puisse
qui nous aider à lutter contre les
oligopoles qui viennent tout d'autres
océans il va nous aider aussi à
développer aussi un véritable marché
européen pas seulement un marché en
Europe dans lequel les acteurs
américains aux chinoises interviennent
mais un marché aussi favorable au
développement des start-up des
entreprises de nouvelles modèles
innovation européen c'est le travail
quotidiens et très bons que Jean-Noël
fait fait tous les jours nous avons
décidé aussi et c'est en cours des
négociations d'avoir là aussi pour la
première fois au monde une loi sur
l'intelligence artificielle
dans les scepticisme général généralisé
mais vous savez Laurence était avec moi
et Sylvie Brunet aussi et j'irai aussi
cette année moi depuis que j'ai été élu
chaque année j'ai fait en fait en tant
que partie démocratique européen une
mission aux États-Unis
et on va à parler avec nos homologues du
Congrès américain et avec l'équival les
équivalents de la Commission européenne
des autorités de régulation dans le
numérique première année vous savez nous
allons régler les services et les
marchés numériques non
vous n'allez pas réussi scepticisme
généralisé deuxième année
à quel point vous en êtes là avec votre
histoire là des réguliers les services
les marchés
on a on a presque abouti troisième année
nous voulons faire la même chose mais
nous pouvons parler faire parce que les
enjeux les lobbys les interactions entre
les grands groupes les gafams et les
congrès américains sont beaucoup plus
forts que les interactions entre les
gafam et les Parlement européens donc
voilà pour c'est la raison c'est c'est
pourquoi nous devons avancer sur
l'intelligence artificielle après il y a
et ça sera mon mon dernier mot je dois
te répondre sur l'international
peut-être à la deuxième partie après
c'est vrai dans les disons
Jean-Noël a été a été très diplomate
dans son approche intelligence moi je
partage une partie de ces critiques dans
le sens que comme toute les lois
nouvelle dans un thème nouveau il faut
trouver un équilibre entre les respects
des valeurs fondamentales et la
nécessité de ne pas nous-mêmes nous
poser d'autres obstacles au
développement d'une industrie de
l'innovation dans l'intelligence
artificielle comme on a déjà accumulé
énormément des retards par rapport aux
Chinois par rapport américain donc c'est
d'après moi dans la négociation avec le
gouvernement nous devons laisser
beaucoup plus de liberté à l'innovation
pour moi l'innovation sur l'intelligence
artificielle doit être complètement
libre par contre
du moment où c'est innovation doit être
mise dans les marchés doit rentrer dans
notre société il faut s'assurer qu'elle
puisse rentrer dans la porte qui essaie
de roller fondamentale de liberté des
règles je crois que c'est autour de ça
qu'on peut trouver une bonne solution
sur l'intelligence artificielle merci
[Applaudissements]
Alexandra au coeur de nos démocraties il
y a des droits et des valeurs
fondamentales la liberté de créer la
liberté de s'exprimer or les IA
génératives percutent de plein faire de
plein fouet le monde de la culture
aujourd'hui on sait qu'une génération
peut générer des contenus en s'inspirant
de ceux dont elle s'est nourrit
donc quel problème ça pose pour le monde
de la culture et puis si on regarde les
conséquences est-ce qu'on va redéfinir
ce qu'est une œuvre artistique une
création est-ce que tout ça va
complètement percuter notre civilisation
je prends un micro merci beaucoup alors
merci à Laurence moi je me réjouis
d'être ici à nouveau avec vous à
discuter de sujets dont on a l'habitude
de discuter et ravi de voir Luc presque
tous les jours maintenant
quelle chance alors d'abord juste un mot
pour répondre à l'opposition qu'on peut
voir parfois entre la régulation et
l'innovation
d'abord il faut entendre vraiment ce
qu'on veut dire par régulation la
régulation c'est pas nécessairement des
règles dures des règles
sanctionnatrices au contraire la
régulation ça passe aussi par l'éthique
ça passe aussi par des mesures
incitatives ça passe aussi par des
mesures éducatives comme alors mesures
éducatif pas au sens pénal bien sûr mais
mesures éducative au sens formation
comme l'a dit Luc de la société
formation tout au long de la vie je
crois qu'on a un très gros travail aussi
à faire avec ça et donc moi je suis
vraiment contre cette voilà une
présentation qui consisterait à opposer
la la régulation et l'innovation la
régulation a toujours accompagné les
innovations et c'est vrai comme l'a dit
Sandro on est des citoyens européens et
c'est normal qu'on est un certain nombre
de valeurs qu'on n'est pas en et qu'on
n'est pas en vie de dire renoncer par
exemple la notation sociale comme ça se
fait en Chine bah non on n'en veut pas
on veut pas qu'on nous interdise
d'inscrire notre gamin à l'école parce
que parce qu'on a critiqué le pouvoir en
place parce qu'on a traversé en dehors
des clous parce que ça c'est des choses
qui nous tiennent à cœur quand en tant
que citoyen européen et je crois que
c'est important qu'on le fasse mais
c'est important aussi qu'on soutienne
les innovations en Europe pour ben voilà
pour exister économiquement dans dans le
monde et pas seulement au niveau
européen alors après pardon du coup je
reviens un peu sur un autre sujet qui
est le sujet de la culture qui est un
sujet aussi de démocratie et de droit
fondamental parce que la culture c'est
quoi c'est la liberté de création c'est
la liberté d'expression c'est présenté
par les plus grandes chartes ou
déclaration ou convention internationale
donc c'est un droit de l'homme comme on
dit un droit fondamental et c'est vrai
que
l'intelligence artificielle générative
interroge un petit peu les règles
traditionnellement applicables en
matière de droit d'auteur en matière de
droit voisin des droits d'auteur donc
toutes les règles qui sont applicables à
la création en deux temps d'abord ça
interroge les règles en amont puisque
vous savez que les IA génératives elles
sont entraînées elles sont entraînées
sur des corpus des corpus de textes des
corpus d'image la question se pose de
savoir si cet acte d'entraînement
c'est-à-dire qui consiste à reproduire
une création qui peut être protégée à la
déconstruire pour en tirer des tendances
des corrélations et pour pouvoir ensuite
générer un résultat et bien est-ce que
cet acte en amont c'est un axe
d'exploitation
est-ce que les auteurs est-ce que les
artistes interprètent doivent donner
leur autorisation pour cet acte ou pas
la question se pose partout dans le
monde
en Europe on a imposé une exception une
exception de fouilles de textes et de
données on parle aussi de texte and data
mining mais cette exception qui a été
imposée par un texte en 2019 et bien on
peut en sortir c'est à dire que quand on
est auteur on peut dire moi je ne veux
pas que mes créations soient fouillées
du coup on se retrouve en fait dans une
dans la même situation qu'auparavant on
a une exception mais on peut revenir sur
sur cette exception donc on se retrouve
sur la même mais c'est pas juste quelque
chose qui interroge en Europe c'est
quelque chose qui interroge aux
Etats-Unis aux États-Unis il y a plein
de procès en cours dans tous les
secteurs art graphique
écrit jeux vidéo Game of Thrones
tous les auteurs tous les titulaires de
droits attaquent justement pour savoir
pour avoir cette réponse est-ce que en
amont on a un acte d'exploitation ou pas
donc ça c'est la grande question et
c'est une question qui inquiète beaucoup
le secteur de la culture puisque pas
plus tard qu'hier tous les secteurs de
la culture française se sont fédérés
tous et c'est suffisamment rare pour le
pour le noter vous avez peut-être vu une
tribune qui a été adressée à madame la
Première ministre et qui est paru
notamment dans la presse justement pour
lui dire attention au moment où on vote
l'artificiel intelligence art il y a ce
sujet de qui est quand même très
important et qui nous inquiète c'est
peut-être pas un sujet qui sera réglé
tout de suite c'est peut-être un sujet
qui sera réglé plus tard mais en tout
cas c'est un sujet d'importance pas
seulement en France pas seulement en
Europe mais dans le monde entier et puis
il y a une deuxième partie c'est l'aval
c'est à dire ce qui sort de
l'intelligence artificielle là output
comme on dit est-ce que c'est une œuvre
vous avez une œuvre au sens du droit
quoi comme on l'entend une oeuvre de
l'esprit on dit en droit d'auteur il y a
d'abord un grand principe qu'on doit
vraiment tous reconnaître c'est le
principe d'humanité dans la création
la création artistique elle est humaine
donc une machine elle ne crée pas
certains ont porté l'idée d'une
personnalité juridique pour les machines
pour leur donner des droits bon ça c'est
du c'est du fantasme c'est bien ça ça
fait le buzz souvent d'ailleurs moi je
suis assez rétrograde quand je suis dans
une enceinte comme ça on se dit oh là là
rien à vendre maintenant j'ai rien à
vendre parce que la machine c'est un
outil et donc la machine elle ne crée
pas en revanche la machine elle va
pouvoir venir au soutien de la création
au soutien de la chaîne de distribution
au soutien aussi de la production grâce
à l'intelligence artificielle et voilà
donc pour toutes ces raisons il y a
aussi une réflexion à mener sur Laval
mais encore une fois ne pastigmatiser
l'utilisation de l'intelligence
artificielle ne surtout pas opposé le
droit et l'innovation mais en faire un
couple qui avance ensemble pour
favoriser justement l'innovation
Luc Julia je vous ai vu plisser les yeux
par moment vous voulez réagir
je veux toujours réagir moi
il plissait aussi
oui je pense qu'il y a une chose très
très importante sur cette créativité et
sur le fait que ces machines ne créent
pas
on a fait des erreurs quand on a appelé
intelligence artificielle l'intelligence
artificielle je pense qu'on aurait pas
dû appeler ça comme ça parce que c'était
ça n'a rien à voir avec l'intelligence
en fait ce sont que des outils qui sont
assez finalement assez simple mais on
n'a pas fait d'erreur quand on a appelé
les IA génératif via génératives parce
qu'elles ne font que générer on n'a pas
appelé ça et à créative de temps en
temps il y a quelques personnes qui font
l'erreur d'appeler ça desiat créative
c'est une erreur elle ne craint rien
elle ne crée strictement rien à la
créativité elle est reste du côté de
l'humain qu'on vient de dire et c'est
très très enfin on s'en rend compte
assez fascinant on parle de révolution
par exemple quand on parle de tchadipiti
ou de mid-journée en fait ces îles
génératives en fait il y a pas vraiment
de révolution c'est une évolution qui
date
depuis les 67 dernières années qu'on a à
créer l'intelligence artificielle et
donc s'il y a une révolution dans tchat
Jippy elle est pas dans gipiti qui est
la partie elle est dans chat et donc le
fait que maintenant j'ai cette
accessibilité dont je parlais tout à
l'heure qui me permet de facilement
utiliser l'outil effectivement je vais
pouvoir exacerber ma créativité grâce à
ça si je prends mis de journée qui est
ce générateur d'images je vais pouvoir
dans mes journées avoir un prompt le
prompt dans lequel je vais pouvoir
m'exprimer et je vais pouvoir créer à
travers ce prompt par exemple si je veux
dire quelque chose comme dessine-moi une
vache verte sur la Tour Eiffel d'accord
et ben ça va me générer des vaches
vertes sur la Tour Eiffel certainement
beaucoup mieux que moi que ce que
j'aurais fait moi avec mes petites mains
et mais la création même l'idée même de
la vache verte sur la Tour Eiffel qui a
l'air un peu débile comme ça donc merci
c'est moi c'est moi qui l'ai créé et
donc c'est là où il faut vraiment
comprendre que ces outils ils exercement
nos capacités comme l'a fait Photoshop
il y a quelques années pour pour des
artistes aussi qui ont décidé de faire
de l'art digital et des choses comme ça
donc
là en général
peut utiliser ces outils et va utiliser
ces outils et il va nous ouvrir des
nouvelles de nouveaux horizons qui vont
être très très intéressants
merci beaucoup donc Jean-Noël aussi
froncer les sourcils merci non non merci
Laurence
vous étiez d'accord un point très
important qui a été évoqué par Sandro
qui a été voté par Alexandra et qui
était en réalité dans ton introduction
est-ce que l'innovation et la régulation
sont contradictoires elles ne le sont
pas en général et d'ailleurs si avec nos
députés du groupe riniu avec notre
commissaire qui sera là demain avec le
président de la République on a voulu
construire une régulation unifiée en
Europe pour le numérique c'est aussi
parce qu'on considère qu'en unifiant le
marché européen sur ces questions là on
offre aux innovateurs un marché plus
vaste qui leur permet de mieux innover
et en tout cas de se développer plus
rapidement plutôt que d'aller chercher
ailleurs
à l'extérieur de l'Europe des champs de
développement mais en revanche lorsque
nous sommes comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui à un moment de bascule ou se
joue la domination technologique pour
les décennies à venir alors l'innovation
et la régulation peuvent devenir
contradictoires et c'est vrai que nous
allons nous opposer avec beaucoup de
force
à des dispositions que le Parlement
européen a intégré dans le règlement en
cours de discussion car nous considérons
qu'elle pourrait nous empêcher de
maîtriser en France et en Europe ces
outils dont nous sommes en train de
parler et je vais vous dire quelque
chose si depuis 15 ans nous n'avons rien
pu faire contre l'irresponsabilité des
géants du numérique qui ont laissé
prospérer en leur sein la haine et la
violence qui ont laissé nos enfants se
faire
cyber-harcelés qui ont laissé la
désinformation prospérer sur leur
plateforme et qui ont pillé nos éditeurs
de presse c'est parce qu'il n'avait pas
la même vision du monde et que nous
n'avions pas de prise sur eux et qu'il a
fallu 15 ans il a fallu résister à
toutes les forces à toutes les
puissances du lobbying et de l'argent
pour imposer une régulation européenne
parce que nous n'avions pas en Europe
ces géants du numérique qui auraient pu
refléter dans la manière dont il
fonctionnait nos valeurs notre vision de
l'homme de sa dignité et de la nécessité
de la protéger et donc au moment où nous
sommes à deux doigts
au moment où nous sommes à deux doigts
parce que nous sommes à deux doigts
grâce à des gens comme Luc Julia et
grâce à bien d'autres qui quittent les
laboratoires des géants du numérique
pour revenir en France nous sommes à
deux doigts de pouvoir maîtriser la
technologie plutôt que de dépendre une
nouvelle fois de géants qui ne sont pas
nés en Europe il nous faut faire
attention il nous faut être vigilant à
ne rien mettre en travers du chemin qui
ceux qui aujourd'hui travaillent dur
pour que nous puissions maîtriser cette
technologie donc en général l'innovation
et la régulation peuvent et vont de pair
mais dans les moments critiques il faut
choisir son combat et le nôtre c'est la
maîtrise de la technologie pour
l'indépendance de la France et de
l'Europe
donc discussion à venir entre le
Parlement et le Conseil bien justement
pour pour continuer sur cette idée qui
sont la vision qu'on a de modèles de
société qui se reflète dans la manière
dont on organise notre innovation et
notre manière de procéder dans des
révolutions de rupture Sandro Gozzi sur
cette vision du monde on a des approches
tu disais tout à l'heure finalement les
États-Unis nous regardent quand on
régule mais dans le même temps ils ont
une approche très différente de on crée
et après on réfléchit la Chine la
puissance chinoise a aussi sa vision de
l'IA qui est comme l'a dit Alexandra
bensamun tout à l'heure un outil de pour
édifier et consolider une société de
surveillance alors est-ce que tu peux
nous faire un panorama de ce qui se
dessine à l'échelle mondiale sur ces
questions et encore une fois est-ce que
le modèle européen le modèle de valeur
l'emportera
oui moi je crois que tout d'abord
c'est seulement en Europe 1
qu'on pouvait qu'on peut avancer et nous
avons avancé grâce au fait qu'on a
choisi finalement en 2019 des attaquer à
ces questions au combien nécessaire au
combien urgentes et des services
numériques et des marchés numériques on
est européens et nous devons continuer
devant continuer parce que nous sommes
en train de développer bien sûr il y a
des difficultés bien sûr il y a aussi
des interactions discussions entre les
ministres et les parlements et les
parlementaires européens mais nous
devons nous devons avancer parce que
nous sommes en train de développer ils
voient européenne au numérique qui est
unique au monde et qui a la spécificité
d'être les PREMIERS la première
tentative au monde des soumettre la
question du numérique au à certains
valeurs fondamentales et nous sommes en
train de développer un modèle qui est
alternative aux États-Unis ou c'est les
laisser faire complet où il y a aucune
contra et aucune régulation sur les
plateformes numériques et aux modèles
chinois je prends je prends les deux
principaux dans lesquels tout est
contrôlé par l'État les plateformes
numériques c'est qu'on fait sur la
plateforme numérique c'est qu'on fait un
citoyens les notations sociales la
surveillance des masses etc nous en tant
qu'Européen nous voulons développer une
troisième voie et nous sommes en train
de les faire il est clair que et nous
voulons continuer moi je suis rapporteur
sur les développements du de la Loi sur
les services numériques qui est des
nouvelles règles sur la publicité
politique en ligne parce que là il y a
des abus fondamentaux sur la sur la
façon dont les processus démocratiques
se font en Europe et on vous observe et
selon vos LIKES on vous propose et des
contenus politiques on vous manipule du
point de vue politique moi je veux bien
être observé et puis qu'on m'offre des
chaussures des courses je suis
marathonien ça me plaît que je sois
observé sur Instagram et que je reçois
ça avant rien demandé savoir rien
demandé des contenus sur les chaussures
pour les rennaises j'aime pas comme
observe et puis on essaie de m'enfoncer
en tant que citoyen quand je dois voter
c'est ça les modèles européens et c'est
ça que nous vend développer il est clair
que il y a certains certaines questions
qu'on doit aborder au niveau global et
je vous donne et je vous dis je vous
donne un exemple pourquoi
qui donne qui fait les éléments de
langage du chat GPT
les éléments de langage parce que n'en
vaut rien il va chercher et si on
démarre les départements d'État
américain et les ministères d'affaires
étrangères chinois et russe décider
d'alimenter d'alimenter d'alimenter
internet avec leur version des Taïwan
avec leur version de l'Ukraine avec leur
version des je ne sais pas des enjeux
des loto quand vous allez sur GPT
quelle est la version qui est
l'intelligence générative et pas
créative vous donne vous comprenez donc
les défis que nous devons aborder sans
doute un défi d'éducation des
associations d'éducation qui va au-delà
de l'école des sociétés et de l'autre
côté c'est que nous faisons c'est que
nous poussons au niveau des Nations
Unies nous devons nous accorder sur
certaines principes globaux communs et
nous poussons pour un pacte des Nations
unies sur l'intelligence artificielle
sur le numérique en 2024 il y aura les
premiers global comme par les premiers
tentatives d'avoir un pacte avec des
principes partagés au niveau des Nations
Unies c'est sans doute une partie de
notre bataille de l'autre côté
évidemment pour éviter la manipulation
nous devrons aussi nous donner des
éléments de langage qui nous conviennent
à charge GPT d'où la bataille pour
l'innovation à laquelle Jean-Noël
faisait justement référence
alors dans ce moment européen j'en
profite je veux souhaiter la bienvenue à
Stéphane séjourné qui viennent nous
rejoindre président du groupe réunion et
secrétaire général de renaissance merci
beaucoup
qui participe également bien sûr à tous
ces débats de la présidence de notre
groupe je reviens à peut-être qu'il y a
à hauteur d'homme sur la question de la
démocratie de Liam sur une approche
peut-être un peu moins anxiogène que
celle qu'on appuie évoquer alors en tant
que vice-président du Mouvement
Démocrate qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
avec lia pour être justement alimenter
des contenus qui ressemblent à nos
valeurs pour développer une IA au
service de la démocratie
tout à l'heure j'évoquais tout ce qu'on
peut attendre de cette nouvelle
génération des intelligences
artificielles pour relever le grand défi
climatique pour relever le grand défi de
la santé mais il y a à mon avis une
autre promesse qu'elle porte avec elle
cette nouvelle génération d'intelligence
artificielle c'est celle de
rendre accessible beaucoup plus
facilement que qu'il ne l'est
aujourd'hui
l'accès aux services publics et l'accès
aux droits dans les cahiers de doléances
du grand débat national on a vu partout
l'aspiration à accéder à un service
public de qualité or depuis deux
décennies on a commencé à pour faciliter
l'accès aux services publics l'accès au
droit à numériser les procédures
le problème c'est qu'à quelques
exceptions près notamment le site des
impôts qui est particulièrement bien
fait mais quand il s'agit de prélever
l'impôt en se donne du mal pour réparer
du compte personnel de formation
également la plupart des fois où on a
voulu numériser les services publics en
a numérisé la bureaucratie et on a rendu
encore plus compliqué qu'elle ne l'était
auparavant des démarches qui étaient
déjà entravé ou pour nos concitoyens et
la grande promesse de ces technologies
d'intelligence artificielle c'est de
permettre à la fois dans la réalisation
des missions de service public d'alléger
la charge des agents et des
fonctionnaires fini les délais
interminables d'attente pour la
délivrance des titres finis les charges
administratives qui empêchent les
soignants de soigner où les gendarmes
d'assurer la sécurité du quotidien
mais au-delà de ça une promesse que je
trouve absolument formidable qui est
celle de permettre de simplifier
drastiquement l'accès aux droits et aux
services publics en permettant aux
usagers en permettant à nos concitoyens
d'accéder à leurs droits et aux services
publics avec l'instrument le plus simple
du monde le langage fini les souris les
claviers les menus alambiqués de sites
compliqués un accès direct personnalisé
et immédiat à ses droits et aux services
publics et si nous y parvenons si nous
parvenons à mettre à profit cet outil
formidable pour atteindre la promesse
que je viens d'évoquer alors nous aurons
réparé tous les dégâts que nous avons
fait en numérisant le service public en
creusant cette fracture entre ceux qui
sont à l'aise avec le numérique et ceux
qui ne le sont pas une fracture qui
concerne un tiers de nos concitoyens qui
soient ne sont pas internautes soit ne
sont pas compétents et qui ne concerne
pas que nos concitoyens les plus âgés
puisque ce sont les personnes modestes
les ouv les employés les personnes
faiblement diplômées qui sont éloignées
du numérique à tous les âges de leur vie
et il se trouve que ces personnes
éloignées du numérique qui voient
défiler devant eux la société numérique
en ayant l'impression de ne pas en être
et bien finissent par se décourager
complètement et fort de ce sentiment de
relégation finissent par se détourner
complètement des urnes voilà le type de
promesses que porte avec elle cette
nouvelle génération d'intelligence
artificielle alors quand on est un
responsable de partie je salue à mon
tour la présence de de Stéphane séjourné
aux côtés de François Bayrou qu'est-ce
qu'on peut en faire comment est-ce qu'on
peut joindre les actes à la parole et
bien on peut évidemment en attendant
patiemment que de pouvoir disposer
d'outils souverains pour le faire
proprement mais on peut d'ores et déjà
expérimenter voir comment mettre à
disposition ce le patrimoine
informationnel d'une famille politique
comme la nôtre son histoire ses
positions les positions de son président
d'une manière beaucoup plus simple d'une
manière beaucoup plus directe et
personnalisée que ça n'était le cas
auparavant où il fallait aller sur le
site et pareil rentrer dans des menus
déroulant etc comment le fait et ben on
se retrouve les manches et on crée un
assistant personnel un agent
conversationnel c'est ce qu'on a fait
avec les équipes du siège on essuie un
peu les plates mais on crée un chatbot
qui s'appelle demo tchat et qui permet à
quelqu'un qui arriverait sur le site du
MoDem à poser n'importe quelle question
pour essayer de savoir ce qu'est la
position du modem sur l'immigration ce
qu'est la position du modem sur la fin
de vie par exemple et d'obtenir des
éléments de réponse alors non c'est pas
parfait encore mais c'est une manière de
rendre beaucoup plus accessible la
politique à nos concitoyens et je pense
que si nous faisons bon usage de ces
outils que ce soit pour le service
public ou pour le retour en force des
partis politiques alors nous pouvons
renforcer notre démocratie
deux dernières questions cinq minutes
comme ça il nous reste à 10 minutes pour
prendre des questions de la salle Luc
gillia vous comment vous voyez ce que
nous décrige Jean-Noël Barrault c'est un
monde idéal est-ce qu'on est prêt est-ce
que il y a toute une culture du service
public de la formation des politiques à
revoir vous parliez d'éducation tout à
l'heure vous pensez que c'est réalisable
comme on est tout à l'heure grâce à ces
outils et ce que vient de décrire ce
joël est très intéressant
[Musique]
et très bien parce que effectivement
l'accessibilité est clé parce que c'est
comme ça ça demande une moindre
éducation ça veut pas dire qu'il faut
être non stupide mais mais c'est
important d'avoir des outils qui sont
accessibles et qui sont donc qui vont
être à la portée de tous mais maintenant
je vais mettre un tout petit bémol quand
même dans cette dans cette technologie
qui sont extraordinaires etc il y a une
chose dont on n'a pas parlé aujourd'hui
et qu'il faut avoir dans dans la tête
quelque part c'est que toutes ces
technologies ne sont pas gratuites sont
pas gratuites d'un point de vue
environnemental
quand on parle de Data quand on parle de
données quand on parle de chat GPT par
exemple c'est 2700 milliards de données
2700 milliards de données c'est beaucoup
plus que 100 000 milliards de 100000
données pendant qu'il fallait dans les
années 90 pour créer un reconnaisseur de
quelque chose d'accord donc on est en
train d'exploser de faire exploser ces
donc du coup de faire exploser des Data
Center les machines qu'il faut pour
traiter et donc une explosion de
l'électricité qui est nécessaire pour ça
donc il faut aussi penser à un moment
donné à réduire la taille de ces modèles
et nous Jean Noël l'a dit tout à fait au
début notre en France on a la chance
d'avoir des mathématiciens
extraordinaires depuis le siècle des
Lumières et même avant et donc on est
numéro un en mathématiques et numérant
en intelligence artificielle donc il
faut d'une part se le dire et ne pas se
flageller sur le fait qu'on n'est pas
bon etc donc on est bon et on a une
opportunité je pense dans les années qui
viennent de
réorienter saisias au lieu d'aller à une
course à l'échalote des datas et des
et du compute de réorienter ça vers
quelque chose de plus intelligent en
fait dans la manière de faire donc je
pense que ça il faut aussi garder ça en
tête
pour être plus vertueux
dernier point que qui nous reste à
aborder très rapidement on parlait
de conforter la démocratie d'être plus
solide or il y a l'opinion se forge par
les médias les médias sont aujourd'hui
aussi percutés par l'intelligence
artificielle
on peut générer de l'information à
partir d'IA nous avons actuellement
aussi à l'œuvre
nous avons aujourd'hui à l'oeuvre un
texte au niveau européen sur la liberté
des médias je salue Monsieur le Premier
Ministre Édouard philippe qui vient de
s'installer aux côtés de François Bayrou
président d'horizon évidemment donc pour
finir Alexandra sur ce point donc nous
avons ce texte qui sera voté la semaine
prochaine à Strasbourg en première
lecture sur la liberté des médias qui
installent un vrai droit à l'information
pluraliste nous avons ajouté et ça vient
de notre groupe un point qui
dit l'information ne peut celle seule
être générée paria il faut toujours un
contrôle humain rédac chef humain donc
quels sont là encore les problématiques
que vous voyez sur ce sujet est-ce que
cette régulation sera assez solide
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres enjeux en deux
mots c'est presque un chapitre qu'on
rouvre on aura le temps de prendre
quelques questions mais quel est votre
réflexion sur ce point actuellement
ah oui c'est vrai
alors deux choses d'abord sur tout à
l'heure on a parlé et Jean-Noël à Paris
de
d'ouvrir un peu nos vannes d'ouvrir je
crois que c'est très très important on a
en France une des plus belles cultures
mondiales la France c'est un pays de
culture notre richesse et c'est
plusieurs pourcents du PIB c'est la
culture et donc on a on est assis sur un
trésor donc si on veut entraîner chat
GPT avec une culture française et
francophone et augmenter la
découvrabilité des contenus francophones
on peut le faire et donc notre objectif
est aussi de faciliter l'ouverture
l'accès à des bases de données qu'on
possède voilà en respectant bien sûr les
droits mais de faciliter d'avoir des
mesures incitatives pour que la France
rayonne ensuite sur l'information et
c'est très lié en réalité
c'est important c'est amendement il est
important du Parlement mais il va pas
résoudre l'intégralité parce que
l'information aujourd'hui
malheureusement malheureusement ou
heureusement où j'en sais rien je sais
pas je porte pas de jugement là dessus
mais elle n'est pas produite que par les
professionnels de l'information la
désinformation c'est bien plus large que
ça les jeunes s'informent sur les
réseaux sociaux et ils vont pas
nécessairement aller voir le monde Le
Figaro ou ou que sais-je un journal ils
vont aller chercher n'importe quel type
d'information et je crois qu'il y a il y
a deux choses il y a la question du
contrôle humain qui est très importante
dans les journaux et ça c'est
fondamental qu'on l'est et puis il y
aura un deuxième temps où peut-être que
le citoyen un moment on devra lui dire
quand le contenu il est généré par une
IA ou pas et ça c'est un principe plus
de transparence en aval
merci beaucoup c'est un vaste sujet la
presse et des points sur lequel on
travaille aujourd'hui
avant de clôturer sa table ronde nous
avons 9 minutes 36 pour prendre une ou
deux questions alors est-ce qu'il y a
des questions oui je vois Samia
oui merci je vais très très courte merci
d'abord pour cette table ronde parce que
en tant que de formation Ingénieur en
robotique vous imaginez à quel point ça
va passionné et donc je pressens que ma
question va s'adresser à Monsieur Luc je
l'ai
en fait moi j'ai vécu donc cette période
d'intelligence artificielle
professionnelle n'est-ce pas des robots
et aujourd'hui je vis l'intelligence
artificielle grand public donc je suis
un peu perturbée j'espère que vous allez
m'éclairer et on avait peur à l'époque
rappelez-vous que les métiers
disparaissent finalement on a juste
évolué et c'est vrai qu'il y a eu des
chaînes robotisées où on a finalement
les tâches ingrates ont disparu mais pas
les bons métiers aujourd'hui j'ai
l'impression que l'intelligence
artificielle s'adresse plus à des
intellectuels donc on a peur aujourd'hui
plutôt de la disparition des métiers
intellectuels je voulais absolument
avoir votre avis là-dessus merci à mon
avis il est assez simple en fait c'est
le recommencement de ce qui s'est passé
avec la robotique c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on aura pu on parle plus
vraiment de robotique on parle de
kobotique effectivement comme vous
l'avez dit les les gens sont toujours là
dans les usines se font aider par les
robots parce que parce que les robots
vont effectivement prendre les tâches
ingrates etc d'accord lias c'est
exactement la même chose en fait moi
j'aime pas parler d'il y a comme
intelligence artificielle parce que
j'aime pas le terme d'intelligence
là-dedans mais j'appelle ça
l'intelligence augmentée c'est-à-dire
que c'est notre intelligence qui a
augmenté par ces outils alors il est
vrai que maintenant ça se déplace de
plus en plus vers des métiers dit
intellectuels et on va utiliser ces
outils pour faire ces tâches dites
intellectuelles mais tout à l'heure j'en
aurai parlé de la machine à calculer de
1642 de Pascal d'accord la machine à
calculer nous a permis déjà de pousser
ces tâches dites intellectuelles une
addition une soustraction c'est pas
facile à faire c'est c'est une un effort
intellectuel ces machines nous ont aidé
et ben ces machines vont nous aider dans
ces tâches il faut être clair qu'il va
pas y avoir de remplacement de métier on
a vu ça justement dans les années 60-70
80 avec la d'accord il n'y a pas
vraiment de remplacement de métier il y
a une évolution des tâches à l'intérieur
de métier et donc il y a une
concentration de ces une concentration
de ce que je dirais la quintessence même
de ce qu'est l'humain dans les métiers
et qui vont faire évoluer tout le monde
et on voit quand les gens utilisent ces
outils quel que soit leur niveau on voit
que ceux qui étaient les moins bons dans
leur métier vont devenir pas mauvais et
ceux qui étaient très bon on va aussi en
bénéficier mais un tout petit peu moins
et donc ça on va voir que tout le monde
finalement bénéficie de ça c'est ce qui
s'est passé en robotique c'est ce qui se
passera grâce à lia
merci beaucoup
est-ce que il y a une deuxième question
deuxième et dernière question
on a parlé beaucoup d'iards générative
et je voulais poser une question à nos
interlocuteurs sur l'IA predictive et
les exigences qu'elles génèrent au
niveau de notamment de la gouvernance
d'entreprise fiabilité des données et
puis surtout
complexité dans la foisonnement des
scénarios qu'elle génère vous avez parlé
de modération dans les Data Center le
refroidissement etc voilà merci
je laisserai quelqu'un d'autre répondre
mais moi je veux réinsister sur ce qu'a
dit Alexandra il y a un instant sur la
nécessité absolue que nous disposions
j'en parlais tout à l'heure de la
maîtrise de cette technologie je l'ai
dit
si nous ne le faisons pas nous subirons
les normes nous subirons la domination
économique d'autres acteurs mais il y a
aussi un élément très très important
c'est que je refuse que nous mettons
entre nos mains des outils avec lesquels
nous sommes amenés à converser qui ne
seraient pas forgé au feu de la culture
et de la langue française donc Alexandra
absolument raison moi j'ai face à mon
bureau la Bibliothèque nationale de
France il y a Lina on a un patrimoine
textuel audiovisuel de la culture
française mais aussi des cultures de la
Francophonie qu'il nous faut mettre à
disposition pour l'entraînement de
modèles qui seront les nôtres qui seront
imprimées de notre vision de l'homme et
du monde c'est très important et c'est
la raison pour laquelle le président de
la République avant l'été a annoncé
qu'on allait consacrer 50 millions
d'euros pour accompagner ces grandes
institutions qui concentrent ce
patrimoine là dans la numérisation de
ces trésors pour le pour à des fins
d'entraînement de ces modèles
d'intelligence artificielle
alors pour répondre à votre question
rapidement et sans trop rentrer dans un
état technique lezia qu'elle soit
logique statistiques prédictive
générative à la fin bon font elles vont
avoir le seul but de pouvoir nous faire
progresser comme j'ai dit d'utiliser
d'abord des outils à disposition qui
sont intéressants
dans dans pour ce qui est de
l'utilisation des données spécifiques à
un métier ou spécifique à une entreprise
comme vous l'avez évoquée ce qui est
intéressant par exemple d'en saisir
générative en particulier par rapport à
ses Ia prédictives dont vous parliez
c'est que les IA générative sont doivent
être ce qu'on dit fin tuning c'est à
dire qu'il faut rajouter les données
spécifiques à notre entreprise par
exemple pour les faire exploser pour les
faire pour les rendre encore plus
pertinentes il y a un chiffre
conciteurais jamais sur tchadipiti la
pertinence de tchadipiti brut c'est 64%,
ça veut dire quoi c'est à dire que les
36% de choses qui sont fausses d'accord
mais dès qu'on fait ce fine tuning dont
on parle avec des données de
l'entreprise ou des données personnelles
ou ce qu'on veut elle a on passe à des
taux de de pertinence qui sont dans les
99 quelque chose pour cent donc c'est
excessivement important de rajouter ces
données de savoir maîtriser l'outil mais
encore une fois quand je rajoute ces
données je rajoute aussi de
l'électricité etc etc
merci beaucoup je sais que je vais faire
quelques frustrations mais je ne peux
pas prendre de questions supplémentaires
en revanche on pourra peut-être se
retrouver
au bistrot au café pour pour finir la
discussion je
voulais remercier évidemment nos deux
experts du comité
interministériels sur l'IA je crois que
vous aurez beaucoup de choses à vous
dire pour faire progresser tous ces
sujets et on a une très forte attente et
je le redis à titre personnel sur la
culture sur la protection de notre
patrimoine et sa valorisation patrimoine
au sens large mais je sais qu'on
continuera à y travailler de concert
merci beaucoup Sandro que je retrouverai
bientôt à Strasbourg merci beaucoup
Jean-Noël barreau j'ai entendu que nous
allions discuter plus avant ce texte sur
l'acte sur l'intelligence artificielle
s'annonce ardu il y aura encore beaucoup
de discussions mais nous serons là aussi
sans doute les premiers à réguler
intelligemment merci à tous pour votre
attention
merci beaucoup merci